how are you
I'm doing good how are you sir I'm doing
well
what the hell are you doing here you
haven't been alive in ages I mean what I
know it's you know building the
spaceships we had a good Glide test
today
we can't we landed everybody was you
know we all had champagne yeah it was
wonderful yeah we uh took spaceship up
to the uh Stratosphere dropped it glided
perfect back in Spaceport
easy peasy man
that went well didn't it that and then
that go brilliantly
like he did
right I kind of think that Elon just
likes blowing up
he learns a lot from blow up anyway
it's just like we've gone live and we
just carried on the conversation but
good evening and welcome to stay track
guys everyone that's watching stormy is
back like storm as
um I gotta add stormy back because the
other two heathens don't watch Star Trek
heathens freaking heathens so I thought
I would get you on and we would talk
about the future of Star Trek we'll talk
a little bit about the card season three
because we loved it a little highs in
those I'd love to hear your opinion I
think people are very sick of hearing my
opinion on them recently because I've
complained about it a little bit
um and even though I loved it more than
anything I loved it so much there's a
few little bits of irritate I mean I
kept going on about it but anyway so I'd
love to hear your opinions and then
we're going to talk a little bit about
this the future
the future of the future yes
well I know I really did like um season
three Picard you know it was totally
unlike the other two seasons you know
and it was very much I thought it was
very much in the spirit of the Next
Generation the actual TV show
you know and um
quickly recognized wasn't it we're
watching it going I recognize this yes
this is
right that's what Star Trek's supposed
to be like
I really liked it it was
I thought the act the writing was uh
top-notch the acting always top-notch
um I like the inclusion you know how
they wove all the characters back
together
you know and
um
you know uh and it ended the same way
that the series ended the Next
Generation ended with a card game yeah
that was a very nice touch and I think
it really was
I think uh Next Generation excuse me
Picard season three was really
a love letter to the fans you know and
was it perfect no was Far Point Station
perfect episode no but
but
it was a really really good season the
thing I love about it and honestly this
isn't a negative thing it was really
predictable and I still loved it you
know they were saying like oh we've
really tried to keep the Enterprise DC
quick and try very freaking hard we all
knew
um and it's like
um but nobody cared when it's when the
doors opened I knew exactly what we were
going to see and I still went yay
like those and boys we are yeah exactly
and I still love I still I got up really
early Friday to watch that episode and I
just adored it
um we knew it was going to be the book
we didn't quite know how and I actually
thought that was really clever how they
use the Transporters to sort of
basically assimilate everybody without
knowing that was deadly clever a couple
of times oh sorry Kerry's just dropping
and she's mad at me you didn't go live
on Sunday you know I'm joking this is my
favorite Channel ever
hope you both have a great day we will
carry and no I didn't go I I got covered
again
are you just collecting you know
antibodies at this point oh my God I
didn't get sick
but I think probably we're all probably
getting covered quite a lot but none of
his testing anymore because I didn't get
sick at all I felt a bit rough for a few
hours they're not fine
um
I was a bit rough for a few hours but
that's fine and then
um
I thought oh I better get a test because
I might kill people if I am go to work
and cough on them because I work with
the album and stuff and it was like
positive again God damn it and
then it was negative by Monday and I had
a negative again yesterday
felt quality for about four hours that
was it
um but yeah but I've scratchy throat so
I couldn't rely and to be honest as well
nothing to talk about
so but anyway we're live this Sunday and
we know what we're talking about so
um
no I don't have no clue but
we'll figure it out but um so
um Star Trek yep highs first of all what
are your highs of the series
Okay so
the the thing that really it really
creeped me out was
the new I guess
evolution of the founders where they all
look like a T-bone without the bone you
know it was like the veins and the
cartilage in in
the connective tissue kind of just
rolling down that really Disturbed the
out of me man I mean I was like
open it
yeah I mean it's like and then the next
moments like well you know how are they
with long lost
the founders now belong on a grill
whereas before you wouldn't ever think
about eating a Founder because all the
gelatin you know but now it's neat
Founders are meat
um
everyone's got that evil part of their
brain
um and then that you would be you would
be dissecting that and some part of you
would sort of go
then you do this
needs butter Founders need butter
so yeah anybody got any garlic can we
get a side salad with the founder please
just get over here yeah table 12 thank
you yeah yeah I mean you see I think it
said I mean because like oh my God now
they're a food source
oh we they can be Seafood they can be
you know they see
the heat was coming off they self cook
yeah so now the founders have all these
other issues now they're going to be
just stock for their food as a delicacy
yeah bad move for the founders I think
and talking about the founders though
um Captain valik and played by um
plumber's daughter I forgot my full name
um something Plummer she was brilliant
she was so all the way through I'm just
like she was so evil but like I mean the
one bit she starts laughing and she sort
of jumps up on her chair and I'm just
like oh God she's so evil
I love it Amanda plumber she can do evil
particularly in the first couple of
episodes she was marvelous
um I think highs for me
um dwarf all day yes
that man is is just Michael Dawn is a
brilliant actor but he kicked ass Wharf
again
um and he makes a very pretty old
Klingon it did it worked well didn't he
man that guy is getting a little bit of
a um like a Colonel Mustard or you know
Kentucky Fried Chicken Colonel Sanders
beard thing going on yeah proper
Southern UT and yeah yeah I do I was
expecting him to throw a bit of a
barbecue on at some point but he didn't
um but oh that's great I loved his new
sword and everything else that was nice
um and I think obviously the Enterprise
D was yes was great
um
I put I think I'm with you I think the
writing I I thought the writer was a
little bit dodgy in places I have to
admit I think they made a few silly
mistakes and again everyone's eyes are
rolling oh he's gonna go off again I'm
not going to go off again well we'll
ignore but there were a few silly
mistakes
um but the show was so damn good I
always said that I did a video a couple
he's gonna say look if it's done well
these things don't matter they don't it
doesn't matter there's a bit predictable
it doesn't matter that it's a bit thing
you know
um nobody shouted woke at this even
though there was a big sort of um
uh you know how uh Captain Shaw was dead
naming um seven of nine
right by her Earth the human name
something
um and that's obviously that was a
little bit of a pointer finger at sort
of like dead name in the transgender
people go through
and that's when sci-fi is done in its
best though because that was
series one or two a picardo they'd have
done something about transgender or gay
community or something and everybody
would have screamed woke at it because
they'd have done it badly they'd done it
really obviously
but in that case they did it like Sci-fi
channel sci-fi shows are supposed to be
done it was subtle it made a point but
it wasn't like alarm Bells going off
the the other thing I thought was and
this was one of uh wharf's best lines I
thought
in terms of people screaming woke BS
about it was
Wharf discussing his Psychotherapy with
Deanna Troy yes that was very passive
aggressive on me you know anything you
know anything Psychotherapy is like oh
that's just what you know and
but well I mean he delivered the line so
right yes that was very passive
aggressive
I just cried man it was so funny
I love the data therapy at the end of
the series as well when she when date is
gone for third that's another high for
me they actually brought Brent's Spina
back and he used him well yes and that
was nice because they used him so badly
in the first two seasons
um that that was that was because he's
too good an actor for that crap he's you
know
um because over the the other the other
uh Seasons he was in they were throwaway
roads yeah you know it's just happened
there for you know
posterity or fancy whatever and um
they were throwaway roles and they
really didn't give him anything meaty
and here he gets to do
transition into data and you know gets
really I got it and plus econ you know
had the the full range of Notions
it was just he he really had a lot of uh
script to get his teeth into you know I
mean it was really really good yeah it
was about time we got to see him do
something yeah and and obviously another
high is just them on the Enterprise D on
the bridge I love that actually
um
how um laforge is the highest ranking
officer
is there
and then you know as the pilot and
whatever just they took their seats well
I mean Jordy took his seat from the
first two seasons so before we got
promoted downstairs and but just
watching it
a brilliant bit actually right was your
known data has to fly does the
Millennium Falcon through the uh through
the deaths yeah at the end he's doing
the thing if you watch it every time he
Taps the button on the screen it like
lit up and it kept up with him I mean
that's just like those little details
that metallis really threw into these
you know
um that ah just I just I've just adored
and it was so it was so good
um
in terms of the displays they were all
actually interactive this time
you know they were actually LCD displays
you know showing the L cars interface
and uh what's his name Michael acuda
yeah Michael was the one of the set
design original set designers on uh Next
Generation
now he uh read an interview with him
about how they you know this time when
they tap something it's touch sensitive
and it actually can change some sort of
state color shape or whatever they said
they use that a lot and you know it took
because before it was always they would
touch something if you saw something
interact it was always a special fact
they were touching green screen green
screen or blue screen on this panel and
then it would change like something
would revolve or whatever
but now this time actually made it
interactive they actually made it so
that it worked which and they spent a
fortune on that deck but apparently it's
going to be heading off to Vegas for at
least a short period to um and they're
gonna they're gonna bring back the Star
Trek um exhibition
period after Vegas I go
I'm coming I'm planning I'm doing San
Diego Comic-Con next year but I'm gonna
go via Vegas and if the Star Trek better
be there but I am determined to do San
Diego Comic-Con next year so I wish I
was going this year I think they're
going to announce Stargate and I'm not
going to be there
so what kind of fan are you
I mean I'm absolutely certain they're
going to announce Stargate on there I
would I would put my my second born
child on it on the first my first one's
my favorite and he's probably going to
do well at school so uh I think I'm
going to be living off him when I'm old
but the second
so um
I love them equally
um but but yeah and I'm gonna not gonna
be there but but maybe next year
at Stargate we will actually have them
like
showing us because they'll be almost
ready for release so like the actors
they're only just the announcement we'll
actually have
stuff which will be just so cool but
anyway back to Star Trek back to Star
Trek
um
Lowe's
from the series have you got any lows
any bits that you just went ah
well I was um
I hated to see Road eye
instead well no it was what not instant
row anymore but low uh
yeah
I mean she sacrificed and I get that you
know but yeah
you know because I always loved her as a
character kind of a renegade and all
this time she's really working for a
naughty people
I liked how they did that because the
whole question with her was is she loyal
what's her loyalty that was the whole
thing of her character in Star Trek now
interested sort of thing and then they
pulled that back through into this
series and then she showed her loyalty
at the end you know that that's that
that you know what she was actually
capable of and I like that I thought it
was um again it was one of those things
that
they really made us think about the
original series The TNG Series so much
and yeah like I I thought it was a bit
of a weird one to bring through a
character to bring back but
the biggest low for me and I know why
they did it and it was very Gene
Roddenberry so I shouldn't moan really
but I just thought it was stupid
um was all the space babies
the space babies
went pop and there's just loads and
loads of babies everywhere
um I didn't
I just thought it was stupid I like
saying I know why they did it and it was
very Jean Roddenberry but it was and it
was very TNG to be fair how many space
babies did we see in TNG and it was far
more but I just hated it I really yeah
what was the the big seed looking thing
there was
about tin man that was the scene yes yes
yes yes
um great episode
uh yeah and then we had the one that
actually attached itself to the the hall
that they take the mick out of in lower
decks yes yes
um and then we obviously a far point
where they were to
Squiddy things so those basically loads
and loads of baby farpoint aliens
stupid
um I just thought it's one of those
things that scientists it's supposed to
be science fiction it didn't really make
any sense
um and I'm pretty sure even at our level
of Technology we notice if a nebula
disappeared and was suddenly relates
with replacement billions of space
babies and I think you know we'd be
looking at that nebula just disappeared
what'd that go you know we know this but
anyway maybe I'm overthinking it I'm
definitely overthinking it probably
so I want one another question I had was
like so how long had roe laryn
been in section 31.
um three or four weeks I don't know
I mean because I think you know there's
a whole series there you know I mean you
know
talk about a conflicted character up and
down throughout the whole you know um
relationship with Picard is like oh
she knew and she knew what was going on
before Picard even knew what was going
on because probably I'm wondering during
the uh McKee the market the Marquis
going back to that was she really on
Picard's Mission or was she on Section
31's Mission already
you know
right I mean it's just
where Picard really didn't know what was
going on it was Ro laryn
yeah she was The Mastermind of you know
trying to figure out the solution out of
the Marquee
and yeah
let me just write a note down I've just
noticed Bob just put a comment and I'm
going to come back to in a minute thank
you Bob thank you Bob thank you Bob
um
yeah so right so we love the series
it's all set up for Star Trek Legacy
which we'll talk about in a little while
um which is oh it's like 99 certain
that's happening
um so but before we do we'll talk about
a couple of other things that were
announced so we are getting Star Trek
90210 it's happening
um this is the academy Star Trek Academy
oh yeah that's what it's called sorry I
keep forgetting they should they should
call it Star Trek 90210 though that
would be so much better
um but yes Starfleet Academy is
happening based in the 32nd Century
gonna follow on immediately from
Discovery
um we'll see how many of the characters
randomly decide to suddenly leave the
discovery and go become teachers I
suspect it'll be one or two
um
what's your initial
instinct
well I've heard I've heard about Star
Trek Academy
in so many different forms it was
initially going to be
you know just character it was that
literally going to be
as Starfleet Academy it was literally
just going to be day in the life of you
know getting through the academy
missions you know how how
you know just life and times it's kind
of like a grad student I guess and then
I've heard other uh different
um
different plot lines different you know
and it's just been malleable in such a
like they have a title but they keep
throwing different ideas at that one
title and now I think it's
and there was so much
I guess Legacy and and so much uh
Canon that was associated with uh the
original idea of you know during the
Picard era trying to get something going
in uh for Academy says well let's just
put it in the uh the 30th Century right
and uh following the legs of a
rebuilding uh Starfleet and then we
don't have the cannon to really to work
worry about it
yeah I like the idea but it was
hopefully there'll be less constrained
in their storytelling
you know yeah I know what you mean I
think the danger to me
if Alex couldson seems to have dropped
he seems to have learned his lesson from
the early Discovery series but I mean it
still leaves but people still remember
it because obviously Alex Guzman wrote a
lot of the JJ Abrams movies and he
obviously seemed to then want to drag
that into the prime version of Star Trek
that's why the Klingons are all
different so the Styles different
storylines everything and it didn't work
people hated it
um but discovery's got a really good
still got a young demographic young
trekkies watch Discovery it's what's
kept the damn show alive so it seems to
me that they're going to continue that
they're going to want to try to do a
show for young people and it should
concern us that Alex kurtzman is um
going to be co-show running this with um
I forget her name but so the last big
show was um the Nancy Drew TV series
um and that's her only other big credit
in their show running this thing
together
this this show isn't for me and you mate
I don't I don't think Stafford Academy
is for us well you know I I did I I kind
of felt that way for a prodigy like it's
clearly a kid's show I loved it
you know I I really did enjoy it it's
it's
I don't I don't get it because I'm I'm
watching it happy as Larry going a kid
10 years old it's not going to
understand 90 of these references
because they're about Voyager that
happened 30 years ago unless a 10 year
old kid has watched Voyager who is
watching Prodigy and then I realized me
yeah it's a 10 year old in us and the 10
year olds that live in the house like
dad what are you smoked up yeah you need
a blood test do you have too much sugar
in your sis dad why do you like it
that it's an hologram Janeway with her
cup of coffee
routine whatever you do it was just
brilliant in the morning and I even got
your Cote to come back and everything
yeah
um did I tell you about how I did a
video a couple I mentioned this on a
podcast I did a couple of days ago on
another Channel
um I did a video a couple of weeks ago
and I talked about chicote being in
pecan season three and that I remembered
distinctly that he was in Picard season
three just briefly
he wasn't I dreamed it
remembered it from a dream and talked
about it in a video
well you know it's a quality channel
here at uh Sidetrack When We're Dreaming
up our next topic just I got accused of
making up occasionally
um really don't but I don't get accused
of occasionally but in that case I
completely made that up
completely made it up but but it was
only when somebody somebody mentioned it
on the video going shikoto wasn't in
Star Trek are you bloody was
wasn't and so like keep Googling it like
oh God he wasn't you know and and I
really do think you know just to Jazz up
the channel we should really do a video
right before the new Dune part two comes
out you know and the title is the
quicksac Cataract is woke and just leave
it at that you know and that's just the
title total total clickbait and then we
just talk about the series as usual you
know yeah
I I genuinely was going to do a I was
going to change all my tiles and just
put really pretty girls on them all and
with the same title and then the video
suggested with us on a different Channel
just to see if it'll get more clicks on
up but I can never bother to do it but I
always wondered if we just get more
views
and you know because people are stupid
they would eat it up uh somebody would
yeah
um
but so so we're not I think it's fair to
say we're not convinced by Star Trek
Academy I I agree with you though I
think the actual ID is great I love the
idea of rebuilding the Federation and we
might get to see some stuff that maybe
we didn't get to see with Enterprise
that we wanted to see you know some of
like the stuff about
rebuilding Federation right what I think
is people at the um work at it a lot and
um and because there's going to be a lot
of stuff about like teenagers
and teenagers from different species
coming together that haven't interacted
for a really long time because of the
burn and everything and
there is a danger that it could be more
agenda driven than we actually do we
actually have a cast yet no has it been
cast in early development
still early development
um even though it was decided apparently
well this is the this is the room that's
gone out anyway this was decided six
months ago but um Paramount were
refusing to sort of sign off on it until
literally about six weeks or two months
ago and when Terry metallis and sorry
when um Alex gertzman said I've got
Michelle yeoh we're going to be doing
section 31 and then Paramount we're like
ah okay and but he was sort of like I've
got Michelle yeah we're going to do
section 31 but I really really want to
do Academy so let's can we crack on with
that any sort of use that because
Paramount haven't been particularly
happy until the last
you know a few months they were really
unhappy when with the early Picard
season three numbers they were not very
good until about episode five
and then they just went you know
um I think there was a lot of nervous
people around because Picard season 3
cost a lot of money to make it was a lot
of money it was well the last two
episodes I think was uh it was a big
lion chair of that purse you know we're
looking at 11 12 million dollars an
episode on average so I mean that's a
series cost like 120 million dollars or
something which is a crap load
particularly the time when they're
trying to shrink budgets and save money
so um so when the numbers weren't very
good at first I think there was a lot of
squeaky bum time
but
he pulled it out the back and he got
Michelle here to agree to the do the TV
movie
um and then he got stuff that kind of me
out of it but um but that apparently was
all sort of like finally decided very
recently
and you gotta Wonder because that
announcement was after
um she won her Academy
yeah and you know her
really went up dramatically when she
landed that you know so her schedule
shrank dramatically but I actually think
it was it goes back a bit further than
that moment because she got a part in
the um Avatar movies so she's going to
be an avatar three four and five
potentially so it was at that point she
was sort of like I haven't got time to
do series
I don't have time so now it's sort of
like oh crap back to the wrong board
what we're going to do and that's why it
all went apart and then Paramount
started saying well you're not getting
section 31 if you're not you're sorry
you're not getting stuff at the Academy
if you're not getting section 31. you
need to do something you need to figure
something out and that was all like
you know if they Resurrect The Low uh
roller and they can still have a section
31 movie if it's all pre you know
previous to the cards screw the timeline
maybe she should have the explosion dude
it's the future it's screw logic
is what we want it's the future of the
future Star Trek's been doing what it
wants for decades
but don't worry about it
think about that
and talking about potentially Legacy
um I just want to wonder what you
thought about again the rumor I've heard
is that parama only want two live-action
shows running at once so
um the current idea is that strange new
worlds will end after season three oh I
hope not
um I kind of hope not either but there
are I think quite good reasons there's a
big questionnaire that was sent out um
to a lot of
um Paramount plus customers
and it talked a lot about strange new
worlds which was that set off alarm
Bells immediately what did and you
didn't like about strange new worlds if
there's bits you didn't like about
strange noodles was it this this and
this and there's like 20 different
options but what you didn't like about
strange new worlds
um it really it barely mentioned
anything else it just went on and on
about but then it was comparing strange
new worlds to the original track
and things like this and it was really
it really sent alarm Bells
um and then I started hearing yeah
they're thinking
that strange new worlds is at risk of
starting to step on the toes of the
original series the more the longer it
goes on the longer it it's on and the
closer it gets to Western New York you
know the original series started the
more right
on trial
yeah and they really it's going to annoy
us basically but also Kirk coming into
strange new worlds was didn't go down
very well in some parts
it was it was not well received the
first six or seven episodes of strange
new worlds were very popular the last
two or three dipped so the thinking is
well have you gone wrong with this have
we gone the wrong way with this slightly
um but what would you think about what
what do you think about the logic of
that for a start
um
well I mean you know it is you get the
idea and uh of strange new worlds going
back to kind of original formula
you know we could you know the the
writers they can always come up with
some way to
tell more stories in that timeline that
he's got between
that period like for uh season two left
off and when he's when he has to change
something or you know
kind of almost die and then be judged I
mean it's just uh
uh I mean it's it's kind of in the
purview of the writers I still think
it's a good show I love watching it I've
watched it it's one of those shows I've
gone back and re-watched yeah
um and uh it's really kind of up to the
writers if they can come up with if
they're clever enough to come up with
something to extend that to season five
or season six
um yeah I think so
um I think it's going to come down at
least in part to budget as well probably
you need to spend less money uh there's
lots that there all the streaming
services are under insane budgetary
restraints
other than that they're all screwed yeah
Disney's
the video I did on Disney on Monday or
Tuesday
um so I keep messing with the lighting
so I've come on and do that that happens
but I'll do that it goes back to normal
what am I doing
um Disney they're looking at about 15
billion in debt
and they lost a billion quid in their
streaming services the last quarter
well they did go big
yeah well also they've started to lose
numbers their their overall subscription
numbers dropped by 2.5 million in the
last quarter
um so it's not even like it's work so
it's um they try to get catch up with
Netflix and they came close but
so I mean yeah they're all save money I
think one reason why Disney
lost so much money is
the uh primarily the um
the fare that they're showing is flat
you've got Marvel movies Pixar movies
Star Wars National Geographic
and the stuff and the fox stuff and
and
that's a very in terms of like stories
you're you're you know it's it's not a
lot you know whereas Netflix they got a
thousand there's got they've got all
these series that I've that's come and
gone for two or three seasons and I've
yet to catch up on because I want to go
see them you know but and those were
those shows were clearly low budget they
weren't really
they weren't extravaganzas like you know
uh a Marvel series you know like in-game
or something sure
you've been making shows in Spain and
Korea and things like this they don't
just make shows for American and Western
audiences yeah some of those shows have
then even gone on to be actually
worldwide successes and I joked that I
got so bored during the lockdown in
covert I started watching the Spanish
stuff on Netflix you know so that that
board I got
um but it's true that you know they do
spend serious money I think they're just
announced they're going to spend 1.5
billion in South Korea on new content
seriously they seriously spend the money
but go worldwide Disney haven't really
but um I agree with you and the problem
is as well that Star Wars
has gone very flat the last series of
Mandalorian was not particularly good
Marvel's basically now on a two-year
flop
um I would say they haven't really done
anything good in a while
um Quantum Mania do I I saw I was in the
theaters for a hot minute and then it
was like nothing massively pumped it's
like it didn't even take half its um
office costs over 200 million dollars to
make it's World boxed off this was just
over 100 million uh Bond and to be
honest mate it's in places it's awful
Paul Rudy's Ace Paul Rod's always Ace
and he is great some of the special
effects are okay but honestly parts of
the story just like what the what am I
watching it's just awful but um anyway
we'll get back to starting right Star
Trek so
I I think that I I do understand the
logic for cancer strange new worlds and
I understand the math the the only
curveball might be that if season two is
hugely popular people are going to be
screaming for legacy they can hold off
on Legacy for maybe 18 months
um before all the fandom dies down
interest wins yeah and and before it
doesn't make sense for them to announce
it as well I mean because it'll take
about a year to develop the show
so if they are thinking end of season
three for strange new worlds they've got
18 months until that'll be that that's
third season will be coming on because
if they're filming season they've
already filmed season two they're almost
going to go into season three almost
immediately
so
they've got 18 months and there's two to
three years between
Discovery season two and strangely
worldstein so the time frame is about
the same yeah
um
so I can I can see where the person I
was speaking to is coming from
I also wonder if maybe Anson Mount
has other projects He wants to do and
without answering that show's dead but
yeah
so he's a really good actor he you know
it's like I never heard on really before
I saw you know some bits and pieces of
stuff other things he'd film is like oh
okay that's kind of marginal you know
it's a
and then boom he really
oh yeah yeah
that was that was brilliant but it was
in something else what the hell is he
was in something I watched him in that
doesn't matter anyway but um yeah he's
just he's not even he's a good actor
he's a likeable actor yeah like him he's
just like you know it's like um it's
like Bruce Brooks Atlanta for me in
Babylon 5 back in the day
in the world but I just liked him you
know just like oh anything he's in I'm
like oh brilliant he was in this
terrible movie about a
um bloody elephant in Vietnam War or
something it was awful and I still
watched it because Bruce blaxland was in
it
um and I just love the guy
um and I'd be the same with Anthony I'd
watch him in anything
um
but yeah so I think that would be shame
if that happens
the other issue is though they are they
do seem to generally worried about Star
Trek fatigue
um and I always think that's nonsense
because if a Show's good people watch it
people are saying now that Star Wars
fatigue is happening a Marvel fatigue is
happening and it's not they're not
making very good teams it's just it's as
you would say it's shaped movies yeah
I mean it's
um
I'm really concerned I haven't seen it
and I'm really concerned about you know
Guardians of the Galaxy volume three
you know I really was underwhelmed by
the Christmas special
so I was like I wanted to like that so
much the Star Wars Christmas Special was
Way Beyond better
in Guardians of the Galaxy Christmas
special
yes I said it here on Sidetrack fight me
[Laughter]
I don't know about fighting
um yeah no it was awful but I mean I
can't see that there's there's a lot of
Star Wars there's a lot of Marvel
there's a lot of these things some of
it's not been very good but people do
get a bit bored and there are like
everything flows in TV yeah sci-fi does
go out of fashion a bit and then you
know it seems to be fantasy this
becoming more in fashion at the moment
and dramas because rom-coms in movies
scenes we're coming back we haven't had
the D we have no rom-coms and our Cinema
for years and all of a sudden there's
you know there's a couple and so it just
there are ropes and flows of these
things
um but I always think
pecan season three proves though that
you know it's that if you make a good
show people will watch it and that was
the highest rated Star Trek shows
ever
you know it's absolutely smashed all the
records so good
but I don't think Starfleet Academy will
will have those highs I really don't
um but I do think our next topic Star
Trek Legacy could so first of all how
how important do you think it is that
Terry matalis has to be in charge of
that show
well I I definitely think it'd be a a
plus you know it's um
like you said the whole Creative Group
you know especially at Paramount have
learned a lot
you know from
what they produce for Discovery in all
the other shows along the way
and I really
I think everybody has learned those
lessons and um
and I think especially the guys that are
looking at the bottom line really are
paying attention to how these stories
are
you know it really needs to be before
the fans it doesn't need to be for any
other any other reason you know
exactly I think that this whole thing
about oh it's just all it's just fan
service what's wrong with that if it's
done well
fan service is why I've been watching
Doctor Who since the 70s man
exactly give us what we want for God's
sake what's wrong with that yeah it's
yeah
it's um
you know it's like good
you know we we demanded this or you gave
us good we're the customer right exactly
right God damn it so here's a rumor I've
heard twice you'd probably know better
than I would
um
Ronald D Moore coming back to Star Trek
universe
that would be amazing I've not I will be
asking
I don't think he's doing anything at the
moment so that would Outlander was the
last thing he was doing and it's
it's done isn't it I think so
um
it would make sense I mean for what
though
oh I don't know I just I whatever
project he wants to do I think they
would gladly suck up
because he he was he was one of the
primary I mean him and robbery I mean he
wrote a lot of episodes for uh Next
Generation it made his career
um maybe his career I mean he was he was
the reason Star Trek Deep Space Nine was
a completely different direction from
what Roddenberry typically produced but
it was still critically the best
Star Trek series ever was Deep Space
Nine and that was all Moore's baby then
after that he said well I'll do this
other thing called Battlestar Galactica
everybody hated the DM idea until they
saw it's like holy that's awesome
and then he goes comes up with a
romantic show that takes that takes
place across time back and forthies
Tommy why me Tammy whiny I mean he he's
he's
this might make sense into something
else that I heard is that section 31
Alex kurtzman wants to write and direct
it
but paramounts aren't very keen
so maybe
that he'll maybe Ronald D Moore will do
section 31.
I I will ask around and see if I can
find out anything because I've not asked
that question but um it would make sense
and like I said I've like I said I've
heard that they're really not keen but
Alex Guzman desperately wants to direct
Oscar winning Michelle yeah
um and maybe he'll be allowed to
director maybe he won't be allowed to
write it
but I've heard that the compromise for
Starfleet um Academy
was that he would have to go show run he
was not going to be allowed to do it on
his own that they were trying to
compartmentally use the name look come
on Alex you're you're the boss you run
the business you run the company you
can't spread yourself out this thing but
apparently behind closed doors it was
you can't let him show it on his own he
if he goes started going that way again
um it turns the fans off and the other
thing is there is a big chunk of Star
Trek fandom that don't like him and
don't like anything and everything he
touches they immediately turn on so they
say this okay this way it's a compromise
and maybe we won't get quite so much
heat
um I think well I mean you know if we're
looking at like um the Enterprise G as
like a show you know
with uh seven to nine as Captain and
Rafi is number one with Jack thrown in
you know and the last thing that and
this in Picard season three dealt with
the founders which was definitely a DS9
thing maybe this is why I keep hearing
the rumor maybe there's nothing to it
but you know an ex-borg in you know
Picard's offspring
you know that I mean that is in in the
way that the founders they're still
around they're still doing something
over in the gamma quadrant you know
I wouldn't mind seeing 8472
come back yeah yes
I Have This brilliant idea that actually
8472 that was the main boss and it
wasn't the Borg
um and I initially was sort of like nah
really but then actually the guy I was
talked to reminded me that in Voyager
they did come across a fake Starfleet
Academy
that was that had been created by 8472
because they were planning to infiltrate
Starfleet yeah um and I was like
ah
species8472.
they've got a proper name and they've
got to forget what it is
um but um
maybe that is a way they could come back
I don't know because you know so far
Paramount has
tickled all the other you know offshoots
Voyager and uh Next Generation Deep
Space Nine with the you know the
exception of the founders the the do
T-Bones without the bone
um
they haven't touched it man that that I
mean and that was probably some of the I
mean whatever happened the corrosion
where is the erosion has there been any
incursions of the Horizon in the alpha
oh my God just bring back Jeffrey Combs
into anything just they can't making his
own show yeah I'm just gonna I'm gonna
disagree with Donald a little bit I'm
still I agree with you Deep Space Nine
was not Star Trek's number one rated
show oh it got low ratings low ratings
uh and season three or four they were it
nearly got canceled yeah um but that's
why they brought Wharf in is one of the
reasons why they were before it's why
the thing but by the end of this it was
it was some of the things but it's a lot
of trekkies will say Deep Space Nine was
their favorite Star Trek even though at
times it didn't get the most and then
Ellie Anders thank you very much 8472 is
the undyne thank you very much
okay so yeah
um but there are a few things about
Legacy as well you mentioned Enterprise
G
- what was your instinct when the the
shuttle came over and we saw that the
Titan had been changing the Enterprise
it reminded me of one of the uh
the uh one of the original Star Trek
movies
after it was a I think it was in search
was it in search of Spock Maybe
when uh you know there him a Kirk and
Scotty are in this shuttle
and they come across and then we see the
next Starship that they're going to give
Kirk was the uh was the Enterprise I
forget I think it was a
I think they did it in the motion
picture but I also think yes they did it
in um
because I remember like um is either
bones or or yeah we'll be lucky if we
get a garbage cow yeah
I think we get the Excelsior and it's
like no I don't know why would you want
that piece of yeah and then it
comes around the corner and it's yeah it
was the end of Voyage Home wasn't it you
reminded me of that scene you know very
going way way back you know it reminded
me of that scene uh it kind of
introducing the ship as yet another
character yeah
I hate it
um
the Titan was a ship on its own they
didn't the thing that annoys me about it
a little bit is they didn't need to do
it a series called Star Trek Legacy with
seven of nine aboard the Titan
great
seven and ordered by the Enterprise
okay but why well you know uh Starfleet
has a does have a habit of renaming
ships for
sentimental reasons
yeah like you at the the uh Sao Paulo
became the defiant right yeah
um the well the Yorktown became the
Enterprise eh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I just think it was
a little bit lazy
and I think he's doing it because
they've got an obsession with having an
Enterprise in the Star Trek show
but what I'd have preferred
Undiscovered Country you know when
there's the Enterprise and it's flying
off towards the Sun and then the
Excelsior is next door next to it and
then the Excelsior
and there was a big ship not as big as
the captain
I would love the scene with the Titan
and a new Enterprise because we all love
a new Enterprise come on we always love
a new starship a new Enterprise and then
maybe like I don't know whoever's
capturing the Enterprise I I don't know
off Topham Edge but you know somebody
called Data or somebody and then you
know they go see your answer and then it
flies off and then the Titan flies off
into the distance
going to the new adventure that would
have been cool but now it's the
Enterprise but it hasn't had a massive
refit so maybe it's got a bit more teeth
than it did in this series it's had a
year basically in space talk having a
refit
so
because it's not a particularly good
ship in the series it gets ass handed to
it like immediately sure turns up Caesar
Striker went run away like immediately
it doesn't no no like you know where's
our Federation Spirit we can take this
bad boy on no it's just like no we can't
take this on we're crap that ship's good
we're crap run away
um so
yeah it was what did I say Seth did I
say something don't say the Yorktown
didn't I say the Yorktown
oh okay cool
um it is the orc down so if I said
something else sometimes I do so
um so I wasn't a big fan of that what do
you think about the rumor that Captain
Shaw might return in some clever way
apparently that they've thought of
God I love his acting man he he
he really knew how to play a man that
had it up to here you know
you're talking about Picard's
Shenanigans and Rikers Shenanigans he's
just like
[Music]
Cal calm down just just no no you really
did that well and it was just like it
was almost kind of refreshing because
you know Picard always got his way and
somebody finally told the card map I am
very almost immediately after the
episode doing obviously there's loads of
jokes going on with Todd slash Rick on
um his in his Twitter we're going when
are you going to die you keep wearing a
red shirt you're definitely gonna die
and there's a big joke about that he
wasn't even going to make the opening
credits and all this stuff
and I tweeted him and I just said just
saying no configuration man and he liked
it and so I was just like oh that's good
cool
um but um I know I've said to him a few
times it's Star Trek man
you're dead just say no
but apparently they've got an idea there
is an idea that materials has already
discussed with him and it's and he said
he thinks it's pretty cool idea so if
the show came back he could come back
um I don't think it would be a full
Patcher I mean it's going to be like a
bloody training hologram or something
but um it's the emergency command
hologram and it's um no no no no no no
no no no no no yeah should we do this no
no should we go no no but but you know
it's like I think it'd be very cool
what do you think about Captain seven of
nine and number one Rafi considering
their um
relationship
I think it's awesome I mean it's just
you know here you've got somebody that's
still very kind of boardish
you know it still has you know I guess
middle scars from being a board
and then you have you know someone
that's a recovering alcoholic
yes as the uh as number one and
um that laser beam drug thing
yeah anyway it was uh
I I thought it was a cool idea I'd like
to see it you know and I don't know what
Jack's role is science officer or or the
yo I don't know
he's a special counselor or something
but an international advisor special
advisor yeah yeah they didn't mention
the relationship in season three but I
did see a meme where
um Rafi walks through and 79's behind
her and seven of nine looks her up and
down from behind
and everyone's like they still they
slipped it in
my brain wanted to say something then
that I remembered other people are
watching so I stopped myself
becoming a grown-up come on
um like a proper YouTuber at this point
I'm actually starting to remember not to
say things that's great
you're not in the pub anymore
no no unfortunately so I'll just you
know what I would really like to see is
you know uh
I want to see the character bologna
Torres back in action
yeah
I'd really like to see that well the
thing I was going to say next to us
they've been talking with kind of
science talks about a lot more cameos
from Voyager and D space-time characters
and which ones would you want to see
his child I can't remember if it was a
boy or a girl I'm sorry I can't remember
but um
they had a child together
so little cling on Paris
so is that one
well I'd like you know I'd like to see
people on a tourist yeah Taurus would
come back as well but maybe the kid
would be like I don't know
a transport engineer or something
what other characters you do you think
you'd probably quite like to see I've
got one definitely in mind from Voyager
or or display stuff
oh God Deep Space Nine
um
I'd love to see Court back
Elliot and kizzy cork yeah why not yeah
um who else can we do there was a
definitely definitely want to see Cisco
again
for the comics that he's returned he's
back
I'd like to see that unfold more
cinematically than just a brief you know
um
love Kira
yeah I'd quite like secure yeah I don't
see why not
but from uh like from a voyager najinway
was always cool but you know but they
she's treated very well in
um
in Prodigy you know but yeah I think
bolana Taurus
uh because she was just always so angry
and she it but she just wasn't angry to
be angry she always you know it was
how she dealt with it you know I thought
was really important to the character
and she's a great actress great and
she's a great director I forget how many
episodes of Star Trek whatever she's
directed yeah
I think janeway's God come back because
Captain seven of nine Admiral Janeway
that writes itself doesn't it it does so
they would be banging heads or something
um I think Miles O'Brien's gotta come
back and his kids and
um Molly was it actually I think yes
Kiko and miles
well yes yes oh Elliot says it was a boy
Yoshi I thought they had a girl as well
they have two kids in there
I might be wrong
um but um I've watched Deep Space Nine
recently so I should remember that
um but but I'd love to see obviously
those are grown-ups now and I'd love to
see one of those as like because
obviously O'Brien was an engineer and
transport thing I'd love to see one of
them as like um
that security officer or something just
because they've got to have something
completely different job and they you
know and um so that would be cool
um obviously Naomi Wildman
oh that would be cool yeah yeah
I'd like that that'd be cool Julian
Bashir I'd like to see that character
again yep I was just going to say as
well
um Yoshi
um Robert picardo as well
it'd be so easy against us to write him
in and to do something
um I'd love to there's so many different
story Eyes they can come up with though
and that's right the Legacy has just got
such a
like I said it writes its bloody self
almost easy
I mean from from those things that you
know they're drawing up on Legacy how
many episodes are we looking at between
TNG Voyager and Deep Space Nine how many
total episodes
well it's seven seasons of both at 22
Episodes a season you know 21 or 22 then
I don't think they're all 22. so 21
times 7 is
uh
70 140.
uh oh a lot almost 200. more than 200.
so you're looking at like 600 episodes
so yeah 500 or something episodes
um a lot of Storytelling man that's a
lot of Storytelling they have to draw up
on all sorts of characters
this background character Shady
shitty guys at the bar you know
go kill that oil fella
he pissed me off
so um go go get him I can't remember his
name the dude that killed um
oh bloody hell I'm gonna have to narrow
that down guys oil dude that killed
tashiya oh I normally know his name
I'm sure yeah anyway yeah it's uh
yeah I don't think you're bringing cash
of your back no even though she is still
alive but premise is more important than
the characters now I'm gonna slightly
disagree with that because again
I would argue that Strange New World's
premise is and actually some of the
story is not very good and it's a little
bit boring
but the characters are so good it
doesn't matter
um there's several other storylines in
it um Aramis as the oil fella that kills
Tasha
so there's so many that whole and the
whole thing is as well with strange new
worlds and I said this at the time I was
not like how is this going to be a great
show
was because we know where it happened we
know it happens
that's why I hate prequels you know what
happens
yeah I mean we know what runs up to the
Original Series so I always thought it
would be a bit rubbish but the
characters are so good
and the writing is good it doesn't
matter so I would I would agree with you
normally premises more important than
characters but actually I would argue
that maybe they goes hand in hand you
need both
a good premise with crap currency
is pointless and vice versa possibly
because you already got the foundation
yeah Starfleet
yeah
Jake makes a good point too characters
and premise case in point Reservoir Dogs
a film about a man bleed into that for
two hours
loads of characters though the
characters are amazing
yeah yeah
but anyway so that's just I think that's
just pretty much covered that Star Trek
covered when we're at the hour mark
I will keep you through an hour God damn
it well we're gonna run over in 25
seconds but
um but yeah it's amazing I'd love to
just just thank everybody particularly
the um people that are members that are
in the chat so Shelley uh Carey hi uh
let's go back through who else have
we've seen I'm looking for the little
spanner logo I saw more come on where
are you foreign
anybody else
I'm sure I saw something else
anyway if I if I can't see you thank you
so much guys and it's brilliant to see
oh I can't turn that off now because
I've got to go and find the there we go
um
um but again thank you guys it's been
really good I love having you back
stormy
um I love being back we will We if we
have to do midweek videos mate we will
do midweek videos
because we miss you very much so let me
take some time to pitch the other thing
I'm doing I'm trying to I've got this
old laptop and it's just not
conducive to making the decent video you
know so there's this new project that
Jamie and I have cooked up called
cocktails with stormy and it's where you
know I create a cocktail and then we
talk about a random book time
because you know not really random
something I I want to talk about but um
well you you pitched me saying I'm going
to talk about Bobo Baggins walking stick
I'm gonna go in
okay
I'll talk about that for hours and then
they're going he will talk about
we we always discuss TV shows and movies
here we really really talk about books
and uh I think it's there's so much
sci-fi books out there that I'd love to
see make it to a series like Frederick
Paul's uh hichi series you know starting
off with his book uh Gateway which is
excellent built written in the 50s or
early 60s or something I mean it was
just an excellent book go get Gateway
and so there's these books I want to
start talking about to try to get people
you know go download it on Kindle or
something you know
we need to be more than just movies and
television definitely well we need the
channel to be as many different things
as we can be and on that vein I'm also
going to be doing a series of videos
with my son very shortly and because he
is going to be talking he's an Avid
Reader he reads differently he's going
through Lord of the Rings at the moment
he likes them very much good for him
we're going to do serious or uh I don't
read at all I've read the Harry Potter
books that's pretty much it
um so I'm it's embarrassing I know but I
just don't I try to read and I just
can't be bothered but I love a movie so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
he's gonna read he's gonna read the book
and he's gonna talk about the book and
I'm going to talk about the movie that
goes with it and we'll talk about the
differences and he'll he'll explain so
he's at 14 is going to go very high brow
and talk very intelligently and I'm not
going to be able to film
hey how it works yep but we're starting
with
um a Blade Runner and he's moving
um the
whatever it is with sheep mother I can't
remember what it's called sleeping sheep
something or the book it's based on
anyway do
um
uh do uh do um why does sleep he wrote
do robots dream of electric sheep there
you go thank you very much so he's
reading that at the moment for me and
then we're going to talk about the movie
and then I'll actually talk to his Blade
Runner I don't like it so that's that's
gonna be fun I've got to watch Blade
Runner again
um but and then we're going to talk
about something and also before we go
I'm doing a video and it's going to
release tomorrow and I'm really nervous
about it so please be nice
um but I've tried to do a comedy sketch
basically
um the health and safety guy for
Stargate um command uh in it
um who never was talking about this you
know
like a vocational video like thank you
for taking safety seriously here you
know
uh he does it doing he's doing like a
video
um report back to the Senate oversight
committee
and obviously it starts off really or I
start off really positive like you know
I'm gonna do this we're going to do that
another thing and then by the end of it
it's just like oh God
why do they do this and um
so yeah and and if people like it I'll
do them for different shows they'll do
for a season two of Stargate I've done
it before but if people like it I'll do
them for other shows in other seasons
and stuff but yeah it was fun to do it's
a good laugh to do but my acting skills
this time
I put it on patreon today and one of the
lovely patreon and people Dave actually
came back to me went don't quit your day
job though will you
as long as they didn't cancel their
patreon
but he did give me seven out of 10.
and then I edited it a bit more heavily
so hopefully a little bit more
interesting I've got like four minutes
out to make it a bit more interesting
but so yeah we are trying to do
different things for the channel that's
my point
um and yeah storm is gonna you're gonna
start doing some videos Matt's gonna be
back doing video soon
um he's having a bit of a break he's um
he's had a he's I think I I go through
this I don't know about you stormy when
you you know with your YouTube channel
as well that you know every so often you
just get to a point it's like I need a
break from this
it's becoming work and it's not supposed
to be work it's supposed to be fun you
know I mean I haven't touched my channel
in maybe a year now
spaceships
I know I do so and one thing I've been
thinking about doing is I've got this
other channel
um
that I've been working on and it's
but it's just been you know like um
sci-fi and horror old uh old-timey radio
shows and I'm just cleaning up the audio
and repackaging them
most of the radio shows you see you find
on YouTube they're like gun smoke or
something there's really not a dedicated
uh channel for sci-fi and horror and I
think it really think it's missing
very cool well definitely um
well advertise the out of it yeah
all right then guys thank you so much
for joining us that's all of our stuff
go over to the check the link for the
descriptions for links to stormy's
channel links to the patreon page links
to the blah blah blah blah
go on sidetrack.com and buy stuff that's
always that's always good
he loves it when you buy stuff yeah I do
love it because the the more crap you
buy the more why my wife doesn't moan at
me for letting me do this but it's
amazing how the channel now does make a
little bit of money like I said that's
gonna have four days a week I'm making a
little bit of money on it it's amazing
how quickly she stopped moaning
well I bought her something pretty so it
works I'm gonna put it that way all
right
guys thank you so so much we're gonna
say good night good night everybody
thanks for watching we really do
appreciate it
we love you all see you later guys
bye-bye bye
foreign
[Music]